all right well thank you everyone for
attending this is such a large crowd and
I'm very excited what we're going to
look at today is a new package for
making dashboards by our studio called
flex dashboard and well we could start
just by looking at some flex dashboards
to see what these things are these are
all flex dashboards you can see that
their dashboards primarily visual
displays of data and they're geared to
help you very quickly understand or
comprehend a data set if we look at
what's in these dashboards you'll notice
there's some ggplot2 graphics there's
some base graphics although not that
many on this page because base graphics
aren't as sexy as they could be but but
then there's also interactive things so
for example here's a Flex dashboard and
it has some HTML which it's based on
high Charter which means you could hover
over things and read out specific values
and you know there's a lightweight
interactivity going on here
I here's another flex dashboard that
also has this HTML widget based
interactivity but also has shiny
components buried in the dashboard so we
could for example use a drop-down menu
to select a different city to look at
and the whole dashboard updates and it's
using shiny in the background to do this
and now other kind of let's say we can
move a slider and that sort of thing
there's also multiple pages in this
dashboard or other dashboards so you can
look at things over time and there's
so the idea
I'm flex dashboards is you know it's
pretty simple it's just a way to display
graphics tables a little bit a
navigation a little bit of layout
organization to create an administrative
dashboard for looking at data the
delivery of Flex dashboards is the same
as any dashboard you know it's it's your
portal into a data set but on the
backend Flex dashboards have some things
that make it attractive to you the
developer and those things include you
know first of all a Flex dashboard is
created with our markdown so if you know
how to use our markdown you can create
Flex dashboards as syntax is the same
and if you don't know how to use our
markdown markdown syntax is so easy to
learn that by the end of this webinar
you'll be able to make your own Flex
dashboards for the most part there might
be some things I'm not going to repeat
the other benefit of using our markdown
is once you create your Flex dashboard
it's just an HTML document an HTML
document that was created with our
markdown and you could use any of the
channels that you already use to publish
our markdown documents to publish your
Flex dashboard so you could put on our
pubs for example or maybe our studio
konnekt or even shiny offside io to
publish your dashboard and get it out
there for other people to see the other
thing about Flex dashboards is that
they're going to do some work for you in
the background like stash boards
automatically resize the components
inside the dashboard to fit your users
browser window or even if your user
looks at the dashboard of mobile device
you'll do resize and make sure that the
dashboard looks intelligent on their
mobile device as well so that's all
things you don't have to worry about
Flex dashboard is going to do it for you
and since flex flex dashboards are our
markdown documents and since our
markdown can deliver anything that you
can create with our flex dashboards can
also deliver anything that you create
with our you can make it with our you
can display it in your dashboard and
that's a wide variety of things you have
your interactive HTML widgets that's
JavaScript based visualizations we have
your base graphics last graphics ggplot2
graphics but tables in there and then
we'll see that flex dashboards even come
with some of their own bells and
whistles that you can use inside your
dashboards and then finally like we we
highlighted flex dashboards are shining
paddleball so if you want to have some
deep reactivity in your dashboard if you
want to provide our scripts and our
instructions that your users can trigger
just by pushing about and removing a
slider you can do that you can really
curate their analysis experience inside
this dashboard by combining flex
dashboard they're shiny given all that
the Flex dashboard package is actually
very simple and there's not too much for
us to cover what I hope to do here with
this webinar is to teach you enough
about Flex dashboards that when the
webinar is over you could go off and
make your own dashboard today